in this video we're gonna hook up AMD's
latest 5700 XT graphics card to the base
13-inch MacBook Pro using an e GPU
enclosure and then pit that against the
base 16 inch MacBook Pro to see if this
EGP you setup can outperform it in
graphics heavy tasks now we already
share this info before but he got taken
down so we wanted to make sure more
people saw this video because the
results that we found in our testing can
seriously save a lot of people money so
if you've already seen it feel free to
help us out by tapping the like button
and watching it all the way through to
help the YouTube algorithm we'd really
appreciate it with the $300 Razer core X
and the $380 5700 XT the total price of
the set up comes out to 1980 quite a bit
cheaper than the $2,400 16 inch MacBook
Pro which is currently on sale for $200
off on Amazon of course the larger model
gets better specs like the 6 core
processor double the RAM more storage
and all the other new features like the
new magic keyboard in much better
speakers the benefit of the 13-inch is
that it's a lot cheaper and more
portable weighing in at almost a pound
and a half less than the 16 inch pro and
it's quite a bit smaller overall now
let's see if it makes sense to buy the
13-inch pro for portability when on the
go and the GPU for more power at home or
in the office while also saving a good
amount of cash let's start with
Geekbench 5s metal graphics test as you
can see the hbu greatly increases raw
graphics power even more so than the 16
inch pros more expensive 5500 M 8
gigabyte graphics option next up we test
the GFX bench 5.0 and we got over double
the FPS of the 16 inch using the e GPU
setup and in the Manhattan test there
was an even bigger difference around 2.5
times the FPS we then tested the Unigine
heaven gaming benchmark on the extreme
preset in the e GP you performed
extremely well here
upping gaming performance of the 13-inch
pro by almost 8 times and easily
outperforming the best graphics you can
get on the 16 inch pro and even
outperforming the $5000 base imac pro so
if you're planning on playing some
games on your Mac and Ichi PU is the way
to go we actually played fortnight on
Mac OS with this eg PU setup and
compared it to the base 16 inch pro here
are the recommended settings we got with
the eg PU 1080p with a lot of the extra
settings enabled and we actually got an
average of 85 fps and game with it very
rarely dipping just below 60 we played
with these exact settings on the base 16
inch pro and we only got an average of
14 FPS which is completely unplayable so
back on the e GPU setup we adjusted the
settings up to 1440p resolution but
turned off a lot of the extra graphics
settings and this time we got an even
higher a hundred FPS average compared to
the 16 inch macbook pro which only went
up to 20 FPS based on these results it
shows that processor performance in ram
don't really matter much for gaming and
it's all about the graphics performance
next up we tested blenders quick
graphics benchmark in the e GP you set
up wipe the floor with the 16 inch pro
mostly because the 5700 xt has 8
gigabytes of video memory and that's why
this 16 inch pro's upgraded graphics
performed much better as well and now
let's get into video editing with Final
Cut Pro 10 the first step is to select
the external graphics option within
final cuts preferences to make sure it's
using the e GPU in the graphics heavy
Bruce X test the e GPU is 42 percent
faster than the base 16 inch pro almost
as fast as the higher-end 5500 M
graphics but inner 20-second 4k
stabilization tests it was actually more
than twice as slow as the base 16 inch
which means the system is being limited
by something else like RAM or a GPU in
efficiencies we then test a
stabilization again with a 30 second
Canon C 200 rock clip and we saw
basically the same results with a 6 inch
pro being over twice as fast next up we
exported a five-minute 4k h.264 clip
with added effects which is the format
that most youtubers shoot and edit and
surprisingly the each of you barely
helped the 13 inch pro being around
three times slower than the base 16 inch
pro this result didn't really make sense
since the last time we ran this
with a similar EGP you setup except the
Vegas 64 card the EGP you helped out a
lot taking only around five minutes we
discovered that the new ten point four
point seven version of Final Cut Pro
doesn't fully utilize each EP used like
it did before for specific video editing
tests and that's because the metal
engine has been completely rebuilt with
this update and it needs further
software optimizations for EGP you
support so we ended up downloading the
older 10-point 4.6 version of Final Cut
Pro and we ended up getting a much
faster export time in the 5 minute 4k
test as well as the other stabilization
tests moving on to the rest of our tests
with the new version exporting a
five-minute c200 raw clip the each of
you helped a ton compared to the 13-inch
Pro by itself but it's still much slower
than the base 16 inch MacBook Pro and
finally exporting a five-minute 4.5 K
red raw clip the 16 inch pro was yet
again over twice as fast as the EGP you
set up and throughout all these tests
the timeline playback performance was
better on the 16 inch pro than with the
e GP you set up running at higher frame
rates and being easier to edit so from
all of these tests we can conclude that
for video editing the 16 inch pro by
itself is the way to go the e GP you
definitely sped things up for the 13
inch pro but even with the older version
of Final Cut where it greatly increased
speeds it was still quite a bit slower
than the 16 inch Pro by itself so my
recommendation is that video editors
simply go with the 16 inch MacBook Pro
unless you absolutely must have a
13-inch model for portability when on
the go and for anyone who cares about
gaming performance that each of you set
up is the only way to go in the base
$1,300 models
slower quad-core processor and 2 8
gigabytes of RAM don't really limit
gaming performance just make sure to
upgrade the storage because the base 128
gigs is seriously not enough for anyone
who wants to game so if you enjoy this
comparison tap like and click that
circle above for more videos like this
one and you can click that video right
there to see the older version of this
video thanks for watching and we'll see
you in the next one
[Music]